President Trump did not win an Oscar and
he wasn't at last night's ceremony but
his presence was certainly there Spike
Lee made sure everyone got the message
he's not a big fan and today the
president responded as only he can let's
talk about it now with senior political
analyst Brit Hume good evening Brett hey
Chris
so last night Spike Lee finally after a
long career finally won an Oscar and he
ended his acceptance speech with this
take a look the 2020 president's
election is around the corner let's all
vocalize let's all be in the right side
of history make the roll boys make the
moral choice between love versus hate
let's do the right thing President Trump
took exception tweeting this morning be
nice as Spike Lee could read his notes
or Berta yet not have to use notes at
all when doing is racist hit on your
president who has done more for
african-americans criminal justice
reform lowest unemployment numbers in
history tax cuts etc than almost any
other president Brit what do you make of
that exchange well I don't one thing I
don't think it was racist and I don't
even think it was particularly any Trump
he didn't mention the president look
Chris you may have heard me on this
before I think the way the word racist
is flung around these days is a terrible
thing it was a great triumph for the
civil rights movement the the national
consensus overwhelming national
consensus against racism and the word
has been weaponized in politics it's
used often by the left against against
conservatives and Republicans now we
have the president using it against
against Spike Lee who is obviously a
Democrat and the leftist I don't I think
the president has had a line on this I
don't I think Spike Lee I mean he said
some some pretty strong things before
but that was a kind of a unifying
message he said love versus hate I think
Chris you and I both love love versus
hate I would think if you have the
president he'd say he was too so I don't
think it was his finest moment that
response and then there were a number of
comments during the night about Mexico
and the wall here are just a few of
those
there is no host tonight there won't be
a popular movie category and Mexico is
not paying for the wall there are no
borders or walls that can restrain
ingenuity and talent and Alfonso Cuaron
one not one not two but three Oscars for
his movie Romo talking about Mexico and
praising Mexico it seemed pretty clear
last night Bret that Hollywood is on one
side of the wall and the Mexico
controversy and thinks the president is
on the other well I think that's right
Chris but I think it goes a little
beyond that I think the way the way
Hollywood has gotten and with it the
Oscars ceremony has gotten is that
Hollywood is on one side of a divide in
this country and about you know about
whether was about half the country
perhaps and the others and and the other
half the country is on the other side
now there was a time you know when the
entertainment industry thought of its
business to entertain and and and
attract as many people as possible those
days seem to be gone the Oscars ceremony
used to be kind of a national moment
everybody watched it was not politics
drenched the way it is now in fact Chris
I just happened to see it clip the other
day because a man named Stanley Donen
who was a longtime director the man had
directed the famous film singing in the
rain died and he got a 90 in 1998 he got
a career Oscar Lifetime Achievement
Award and he did an absolutely charming
little acceptance speech in which he
sang a song and did a little soft-shoe
and then thank all the talented people
who work from the audience went wild
that's how the Oscars used to be I think
they'd be better off as they were that
way today political analyst and movie
critic Brit Hume Fred always a pleasure
thanks Chris